anyway all kidding aside thank you uh
for taking the time
i uh
today marks one month since russia
began its carnage in ukraine the brutal
invasion of ukraine
and
we held a nato summit the very next day
at that time my overwhelming objective
wanting that summit
was to have absolute unity on three key
important issues among our nato and
european allies
first was
to support ukraine with military and
humanitarian assistance
second was
to impose the most significant the most
significant sanctions economic sanction
regime ever in order to [ __ ] putin's
economy and punish him for his actions
third was to fortify the eastern flank
of our nato allies who were obviously
very very concerned and somewhat at
worry to what would happen
we accomplished all three of these and
today we're determined to sustain those
efforts and to build on them
the united states is committed to
provide over 2 billion dollars in
military equipment in ukraine since i
became president
and i air systems anti-armor systems
ammunition
and our weapons are flowing into ukraine
as i speak
and today i'm announcing the united
states are prepared to commit
more than one billion dollars in
humanitarian assistance to help get
relief to millions of ukrainians
affected by the war in ukraine
many ukrainian refugees will uh will
wish to stay in europe closer to their
homes
but we've also will welcome 100 000
ukrainians to the united states with a
focus on reuniting families
and we will invest 320 million dollars
to bolster democratic resilience and
defend human rights in ukraine and
neighboring countries
we're also coordinating
with the g7 and the european union on
food security as well as energy security
and i'll have more to say about that
tomorrow
we're also announcing new sanctions of
more than 400 individuals and entities
aligned with in alignment with the
european union
more than 300 members of the douma
oligarchs and russian defense companies
that fuel the russian war machine
in addition to the 100 000 u.s forces
now stationed in europe to defend nato
territory
nato established as you already know
four new battle groups in romania
hungary
bulgaria and slovakia to reinforce the
eastern front
putin was banking on nato being split
my early conversation with him in
december in early january it was clear
to me he didn't think we could sustain
this cohesion
nato has never never been more united
than it is today
putin is getting exactly the opposite
what he intended to have as a
consequence of going into ukraine
we've built that same unity with our
european the european union and with a
leading democracies of the g7 in the g7
so i want to thank you
and i'll be now happy to take your
questions since there's so many people
out there i'm going to been given a list
now how about chris or the associated
press first question thank you mr
president
so you've warned about the real threat
of chemical weapons being used have you
gathered specific intelligence that
suggests that president putin is
deploying these weapons moving them to
position or considering their use
and would the u.s or nato respond with
military action if he did use chemical
weapons you know on the first question i
can't answer that i'm not going to give
you intelligence data number one number
two
we would respond we would respond if he
uses it the nature of the response would
depend on the nature of the use
uh
josh of bloomberg
perhaps i'll just project mr president
uh thank you very much i fired your
voice i haven't been elected a lot
earlier i'll give it a try it's got a
long arm thank you uh can you uh talk to
us about two things sir one since your
conversation with president xi of china
have you seen any indications of action
or
lack of action from china that has led
you to believe whether they will
intervene and help russia either with
the sale of arms
or or the provision of supplies to
support this war in ukraine and secondly
uh can you say whether this uh the
conversation today turned to the subject
of food shortages and what the us will
do to address wheat shortages in
particular as a result of this war thank
you on the first question relating to uh
president xi jinping of china
i had a a very straightforward
conversation with
she
now i guess it's six days ago seven days
ago in that range
and
i
made it clear to him i made no threats
but i made it clear to him
that make sure he understood the
consequences of him helping russia as
had been reported and as as what was
expected
and
i made no threats but i pointed out the
number of
american and foreign corporations left
russia as a consequence of their
barbaric behavior
and i indicated that
i knew how much he because we had long
discussions in the past
about his interest in
making sure he had economic relations
and economic growth with europe and the
united states
and indicated that he'd be putting
himself at significant jeopardy
and those
in those aims if in fact he were to move
forward
i
am not going to comment on any detail
about what we know or don't know
as a consequence of that conversation
but uh
tomorrow is
tomorrow or next monday that ursula is
having that conference with china
the first
on april 1st we've had discussions
because i think that um
china understands that
uh its economic futures much more
closely tied to the west
than it is to russia
and so i i i'm hopeful
that he uh he does not get engaged we
also did discuss today
that there's a need for us to set up
nato to set up and and the eu
to set up a system whereby we have an
organization looking at
who has violated any of the sanctions
and where and when and how they violated
them
and that's something we're going to put
in train it's not done yet
so uh with regard to uh um uh she i uh i
have not nothing more to report with
regard to food shortage yes we did we
talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real the the
price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
and because both uh russia and ukraine
have been the bread basket of europe in
terms of wheat for example just give one
example
but we had a long discussion
in the g7
with uh um
the uh
with both uh the united states which has
a significant the third largest producer
of wheat in the world
as well as canada which is also a major
major producer
and we both talked about how we could
increase and disseminate more rapidly
food food shortages in addition to that
we talked about
urging all the european countries and
everyone else to
end trade
restrictions on
on sending uh
limitations on sending food abroad
and so we are in the process of working
out with our european friends
what it would be what it would take to
help alleviate the concerns relative to
food shortages we also talked about a
significant major u.s investment among
others in terms of providing for
the need for
humanitarian assistance including food
as we move forward
to reena of the wall street journal
out you don't get hit in the head there
now
mr president in your view does president
zielinski need to cede any ukrainian
territory in order to gain a ceasefire
with russia or is that completely off
the table and then also do you think
that russia needs to be removed from the
g20
on the latter point my answer is yes
that depends on the g20
um i
that was raised today and uh
i raised the possibility if that can't
be done if indonesia and others do not
agree
then we should in my view
ask to have
both
um ukraine uh be able to attend the
meetings as well as uh
um
basically ukraine being able to attend
the g20 meeting and observe
with regard to what was the first
question
that is a total judgment based on
ukraine
nothing about ukraine without ukraine
i don't believe that they're going to
have to do that but that's a judgment
there's negotiations that are
discussions i should say that have taken
place that i have not been part of
including ukrainians
and it's uh it's it's their judgment to
make
um
cecilia abc
there you are
oh oh
thank you
um sir you've made it very clear in this
conflict that you do not want to see
world war iii but is it possible that in
expressing that so early that you were
too quick to rule out direct military
intervention in this war could putin
have been emboldened knowing that you
are not going to get involved directly
in this conflict no no
and to clarify on chemical weapons could
if chemical weapons were used in ukraine
would that trigger a military sp
response from nato
it would be it would trigger a response
in kind whether or not you're asking
whether nato would cross
we'd make that decision at the time and
my final question because you're heading
to poland tomorrow do you think that
getting a first-hand look at the effects
of this war
on these millions of ukrainians who have
fled their country could change the way
that you might respond
i don't think so because i've been to
many many war zones
i've been as
refugee camps i've been in war zones for
the last 15 years and it's it's it's
devastating and uh but the thing you
look at the most is you see these young
children
you see children without parents that
are in those camps or in
refugees you see women and husbands and
men and women who are completely lost
and have no nose you see the look that
blank look on their face
that absolute feeling of my god where am
i what's going to happen to me
and so
it what it will do it will reinforce my
commitment to have the united states
make sure we are a major piece
of dealing with the relocation of all
those folks as well as humanitarian
assistance needed both inside ukraine
and outside ukraine for example this is
not something
that poland or romania or germany should
carry on their own
this is an international responsibility
the united states is the leader one of
the leaders in the international
community has an obligation to be
engaged to be engaged and do all we can
to ease the suffering and pain of
innocent women and children and men for
that matter throughout the throughout
ukraine
and those who have made it across the
border i plan on attempting to see those
folks as well as i hope i'm going to be
able to see
i guess i'm not supposed to say where
i'm going am i
but anyway i hope i get to see
[Music]
a lot of people
um
[Music]
marcus or der spiegel
thanks mr president
um
there is a presidential election coming
up in 2024 and as you know there are
white yes
that's true
and there are widespread concerns in
europe that
a figure like your predecessor maybe
even your predecessor himself
might get elected president again
so are there any steps anything
uh you are trying to do and nato is
trying to do here these days
to prevent
what you're trying to do uh becoming
undone two years from now thank you
no that's not how i think of this i've
been dealing with foreign policy
for longer than anybody is involved in
this process right now
i have no concerns about
the impact i made a commitment when i
ran this time
i wasn't going to run again and i mean
that sincerely i had no intention of
running for president again
and uh until i saw
those folks coming out of the fields in
virginia carrying torches and carrying
nazi banners and literally
singing the same
vile
rhyme that they used in germany in the
early 20s or 30s i should say
and um
and then when
the gentleman you mentioned was asked
what he thought and a young woman was
killed a protester
and he asked was asked what he thought
he said they're very good people on both
sides
and that's when i decided i wasn't going
to be quiet any longer
and when i ran this time and i think the
american press whether they look at me
favorably or unfavorable acknowledges i
made a determination
nothing is worth
no election is worth my not doing
exactly what i think is the right thing
not a joke
i'm too long on the tooth to fool with
this any longer
and so
we're a long way off in elections a long
way off
my focus of any election is on making
sure that we retain the house in the
united states senate
so that i have the room to continue to
do the things that i've been able to do
in terms of grow the economy and deal
in a rational way with american foreign
policy and lead the world
lead be the leader of the free world so
uh um but it's not a it's not a logical
question for someone to ask
i say to people at home
imagine if we sat and watched the
uh the doors of the bundestag broken
down and
police officers killed and hundreds of
people storming in
or imagine if we saw that happening in
the british parliament or whatever how
would we feel
and
one of the things that i take some
solace from
is i don't think you'll find any
european leader
who
thinks that
i am not up to the job
um and i mean that sincerely it's not
like whoa it's that's that the point is
that one the first g7 meeting i attended
like the one i did today
was in great britain and i sat down and
i said america's back
and one of the one of my counterparts
colleagues as head of state said for how
long
for how long
and so i don't blame i don't i don't
criticize anybody for asking that
question but
the next election i'd be very fortunate
if i had
that same man running against me thank
you very very much
you know yeah one final question right
halo way hold on a second please
i was supposed to be an hour ago at the
european union meeting and to speak now
i'm thanking you
uh so someone i haven't called on before
you
who are you i'm christina from cbs thank
you okay
sir deterrence didn't work
what makes you think vladimir putin will
alter course based on the action you've
taken today let's get something straight
you remember if you covered me from the
very beginning i did not say that in
fact
the sanctions would deter him
sanctions never deter
you keep talking about that
sanctions never deter
the maintenance of sanctions
the maintenance of sanctions the
increasing the pain and the
demonstration why i ask for this nato
meeting today is to be sure that after a
month we will sustain what we're doing
not just next month the following month
but for the remainder of this entire
year that's what will stop
on making him
change course in ukraine that's not what
i said you you're playing a game with me
i know the answer is no
i think what happens is we have to
demonstrate the purpose the single most
important thing
is for us to stay unified
and the world continue to focus on what
a brute this guy is and all the innocent
people's lives are being lost and ruined
and what's going on
that's the important thing but look if
you're putin
and you think that the
europe is going to crack
in a month or six weeks or two months
why not
they can take anything for another month
but we have to demonstrate the reason i
ask for the meeting we have to stay
fully totally thoroughly united thank
you
so president biden uh leaving the podium
for a second time the second world
leader to be persuaded back to answer
another question from journalists after
boris johnson did just the same he
covered a huge range of issues on the
subject of ukraine after questions from
journalists but first of all he set out
that would have been agreed with his
fellow nato and g7 allies
was support for ukraine as far as
humanitarian aid was concerned also to
impose the most significant sanctions
possible to [ __ ] putin's economy and
punish him for his actions and also to
fortify the eastern flank of our nato
allies earlier in the day jens
stoltenberg of nato announced four new
battle groups to boost that eastern
flank he said that putin had been
relying on nato being split but he said
that nato has never never been more
united than it is today and he said
putin was getting exactly the opposite
of what he wanted to achieve
on the subject of china he was asked if
he had made any threats towards xi
jinping about its relationship with
russia and he said no but he did point
out he said the number of american and
foreign companies that had left russia
and he said he thought that china
understood that its economic future was
more closely tied with the west than
with russia
he was also asked about whether or not
ukraine might need to cede territory if
it was going to do some kind of deal
with russia and he said that was totally
up to ukraine that was a matter for them
to make a judgment on alone
he said that he thought that russia
should leave the g20 they should be
removed but he had asked that if you
ukraine should be allowed to attend
meetings
and uh he also he summarized at the end
there saying that the single most
important thing was that the allies were
united
meanwhile we've also been hearing while
president biden was speaking there
from the russian foreign ministry who
we're told have said that the nato
summit decision to keep providing
support for ukraine which we were
telling you about earlier confirms they
say that the alliance wants conflict to
continue
and the ministry goes on to say that
nato is
reaping terrible results from decisions
to pump ukraine with weapons
so that was joe biden this is what boris
johnson said in the last hour
today i've announced that we in the uk
will send an additional 6 000 missiles
and provide 25 million pounds in
unrestricted funding for ukraine's armed
forces more than doubling the lethal aid
we provided to date
we're bolstering our support for the
nato countries on the front line
sending a new deployment of uk troops to
bulgaria on top of doubling our troops
both in poland and in estonia the
message
that president putin can take from
today's extraordinary meeting of nato
and the g7 is this
ukraine
is not alone
we stand
with the people
of kiev
of mario paul of la viv
and donetsk
and
as president zalensky has said himself
the people of ukraine will prevail
and putin
must fail and he will fail